so i mean both of you it is finally out
how does it feel like we're early days
of being out but amy
how does it feel to actually have it out
there ah
like a really big relief i've been
working on this
really for a long time just and for me
you know going over and over again to
like a really
deep place um just daily
you know down to the tweaking on every
little detail i was just talking to my
dad this morning
he was complimenting me which is very
sweet of a dad to do i
to be able to like not listen to any of
the mistakes or
things i want to change and think about
the details anymore and just appreciate
it as a whole after stepping back
i love it i'm so proud of it yeah yeah
will was there any worried that the fans
wouldn't be there like they wouldn't
come back
i don't think so like i you know when we
in 2017 we did synthesis
which was just you know an orchestral
record and
not unlike what other bands would do
like we really broke our songs down and
rebuilt them to this whole other thing
and um and then when we went on tour
like we don't know what's going to
happen here you know are the fans going
to be there and
and then you know wildly and awesomely
we went out on tour and
everything sold out and fans were there
so i didn't have any doubt that they
wouldn't be there for this
we've got incredible fans yeah amy was
there was there ever a point in the last
like it's been 10 years since the last
original album was there ever a point
that you guys thought like we're done
we're not gonna make new music or was
just
it was just a long break um you know
i've i've come to be positive in myself
that i'm always gonna be making music
in some form but kind of to be honest
at the end of every album cycle there's
a part of me that's like i don't know
like until i have a new idea until we're
on track with
with a plan of something that needs to
come out
it's never like in my mind as this
essential
we're going to go do this time i don't
know i'm really bad at planning
my family uh i just have to you have to
kind of go with
with inspiration like when you feel it
and you have that fire you just
ride it you know and this is the past
few years for us it's been a really
creative time where we all really were
just
passionately wanting to make music
and and to make that our main focus yeah
yeah will it's funny i've talked to a
lot of
artists during the last year and some
are very inspired during this time
some have done nothing over the last
year like what was it like for you guys
making this
um in 2020 even though the logistics of
making it happen
well i mean we started in like february
of 2020 so pre-pandemic
and we thought yeah the idea was to do
four songs and then we
had this major european tour planned and
then for april and then
march happened and then it was like okay
and it sort of changed our whole
trajectory i mean the whole
plan was it was always to release the
entire record
about when we released it but the plan
was to release
a few song at a time over the course of
like eight or ten months
from march onward but the problem was is
that
you know by the time it came to june we
were like we have
we got to finish this record so we're
running out yeah like
we're already committed yeah we're
committed it's like there's no turning
back
well now we got to do it i mean luckily
we you know obviously
there wasn't a shortage of uh
inspiration to uh feed off of
at that point yeah and amy i know you
described this album as for survivors do
you want to explain
what you mean by that oh well
um gosh i feel like that's something
maybe more people than ever in the world
in this moment can kind of
get and and come together on um i'm i'm
at a place in my life where
um i've i've seen a lot i've lost a lot
i've gained a lot too being able to look
at all of it you know
all the way around see life i love life
i want to live life i don't want to
waste a moment
some of that is born out of grief and um
out of loss
and i think that you know you take you
can take the things that happen to you
and there's kind of a choice to make at
some point you know you have to
pick yourself back up or not uh and you
can waste
more moments that you're gonna just in a
blink be missing those two
um if if you're just still lost in the
past
having to overcome obstacles and
especially the losses in our
in our lives our band families had some
major ones in the past few years
um that's that was i think for me the
initial big kick
that made me start needing to process
that
um writing music like getting lyrics out
having
a lot of ideas but i also became a mom
um
six years ago my son jack is almost
seven now um
that opened my mind and widened my
perspective in a really big way
too our music has always been a place
for me to kind of like
weigh the biggest deepest questions and
feelings about life
it's a little bit dramatic but you know
it's it's because of that kind of
release and an outlet that we have to
release
um those those feelings and those
frustrations and all of that
turn it into something good turn it into
something beautiful it motivates
all of us um to want to push forward and
i hope that our music
can do that for other people too i've
seen it happen before
yeah and will i know evanescence has
been on a little bit of a break
performing but really over the past year
every artist has been
on a break for from performing so what's
it going to be like to
perform again like you think your tour
is together for september right
is that when it started it is we have a
yeah the reschedule of the last
yeah rescheduled for september and then
there's some other things on the horizon
i guess you know time will tell but
yeah i mean it's gonna be incredible
like we're really like
this record really is kind of a record
that was built around being able to play
it live
it's just a really raw stripped-down
in-your-face version of evanescence and
so it's built for that
um but i think that combined with the
fact that everybody's just starving for
that
you know that communal and that tribal
um give and take that you get in a
concert it's just going to be incredible
i mean there's good the
the energy in that room on that first
show
is going to be palpable for sure being
away from it when you don't have a
choice
makes you appreciate it like never
before right
absolutely very hungry to play these
songs live yeah that's like the
the new mindset coming into 2021 and
2022 for sure
and yeah amy what you're saying about
how you you know have all these big
questions in your music
how do you look back on say like the
greatest hits of your guy's career
and you have to perform them now again
like you know 10 years later like 15
years later
like how do you look at those songs now
it's such a gift
because that's the part first of all
just on
just playing live music performer level
having songs in your pocket
that aren't a cover that everybody knows
and it's going to sing along to
put their hands in the air it's the best
thing ever but those songs like bring me
to life
has grown in meaning for me throughout
the years
as we have been through so many
experiences
around the world with people friends
that we've made friends that we've lost
just things that we've seen that we
never would have seen if it wasn't for
that first song that got us there
when we're playing that song live i i am
like
living in 3d through time seeing and
feeling
feelings that have been building into
something bigger than myself
over the last 17 years and it is
kick-ass
it is so awesome to have that um and
then you know we can always we're dying
to play these new songs
um and i what's going to be cool is that
when we finally get out and we're able
to do it the fans have been listening to
them for a year
so they're going to know them you know
it's not like we're ever going to step
out on stage
oh what's this one yeah exactly and
finally i'll ask this question to both
you to start with you will
what do you want fans to get out of this
new album
wow i think that this record is a record
that can definitely be listened from
start to finish
and it's so it's interesting and i don't
know you can never plan this kind of
thing when you go into it so i can't say
this is how we planned it but it's it's
like it's a trip and it's almost like
it's a trip
of sort of this pandemic and you can
kind of sense those feelings
interwoven in this music and it starts
with like this
kind of oh man kind of moment and then
by the time you get to the last song
it leaves you with this feeling of hope
and like positivity and like energized
and i've had so many
people already comment on that alone
just saying
i listen to this record and it's
therapeutic i get to the end of it and i
feel so much better he's like i can't
explain it but
and i think that's what i hope people
get out of this a positive message that
you know we're moving forward you know
yeah amy that's awesome i love what you
just said
it's funny because you know um the order
making an album is it's an art of its
own
um and i in this world today like so
often myself included we listen to music
in a way that is
oftentimes more about just songs than
albums it's just the world of music now
and that's important so when we're
making the music i want to think about
each song
being able to stand by itself but i'm
also thinking
this is this is evan essence this is a
rock band this is
a big deal like we have to live up to a
full
album and and being that thing that is
is becoming a little bit rare it needs
to work both ways
um and i am so proud with the way that
it really did
fall together in the end but it's funny
i was listening to you say that well and
i was thinking the way that the album
begins
that music the recording of that was
pre-pandemic
um at the very beginning of the intro
like we were in a hotel
in canada and i had an idea in the
middle of night and i recorded it not
even a microphone like in my laptop
microphone and we ended up keeping that
little piece on the album because it was
it makes the next part sound bigger
because it's so small and weird
um and then by the end the very last
song on the album
it's one of the last songs that we wrote
together as a group last year
well that's awesome and that's the thing
i love artists that appreciate all my
i'm still a huge album guys so i love
artists like you guys that i really
appreciate now so yeah congratulations
on the album
awesome to talk to you guys today thank
you very much
you